[Music]
welcome
to the iron lords podcast
[Music]
all right and we are live laura cognito
here i
love podcast lords of gaming.net and who
are these fine people we have in the
realm of play nyc today
oh hi i'm vicki and i'm john
and what is this game what is this game
called this game okay this is
get a grip chip and it's a grappling
platformer
you play as a chip in the factory
you know that you work in and there's
been a slight kerfuffle
uh your balls got hit in the head with a
cog and
um she's going around like blasting
lasers everywhere and
you and your battery friends have been
sent to the bottom
so now you've got to grapple your way
back up to the top
and save your bed of our friends save
your boss
from the cog that's in her head and
um
[Music]
so how long has this game been in
development it took us about nine months
uh so relatively short period for a game
uh
we're a relatively small team too tell
me how many is this is this the team or
this is more
fun uh yeah we're the core team and
we've got a couple other folks that
we're working with and your specific
roles in the team
uh we're both directors actually but i
did some of the programming that was my
main focus
yeah and i did uh primarily level design
and um some of the levels set art
that's awesome so speaking of my my good
friend laura karagbatsu
and he's telling me it's giving via
commando var
yeah tell us about that yeah there's uh
well if you like fiona commando the
original one especially
uh you'll definitely like this this game
is focused entirely around
grappling uh as part of the concept for
the game we wanted to have one core
mechanic
that would really tighten up and make
perfect basically
and uh yes you can't jump in this game
at all similar to because you have to
use okay
now the thing is that is an iconic
franchise right would you
would is it is it safe to say that was
an inspiration as far as
would get a grip yeah actually we
we came up with it and then um a couple
people mentioned bionic commando but
then i think
and then so it started melding into the
influence and
yeah we wanted to like get that like
really nuanced
feel and you can like just like aim like
totally 360.
and and it feels like you know chip is
in
truly in your hands or that you are chip
okay so i love the name by the way
so that was again part of that whole
inspiration about it you get a great
channel okay cool
and again now as far as platforms now we
nintendo switch currently right now like
what what are we looking at right now
platform
yeah so we're on uh oh we got the light
see that okay we on a standstill king
and so we're also on steam and um
soon to be coming out on xbox
did you say xbox maybe
the game pass people can listen for a
little bit
we're here he's like game plans we're
here
no it's cool but it's awesome because
again we have a lot of fans that are on
the xbox platform
and it would be great to see that
regardless if it comes on game pass or
not
in the platform and stuff like that so
again single player component mostly
right or yes
okay cool and um pretty excited about
that and how far are we
as far as release so we're out on switch
now or how far are we okay we're out on
switch and we're out on steam
and it's on sale this weekend oh nice
nice you heard it here first
no doubt no doubt and last thing i'll
ask you again again we know we're in a
pandemic everything's going on
you know what have you guys learned from
you know game development
during this whole type of condition with
get a grip check
i think uh communication and like
supporting
one another like whether it's your
audience your fellow developers and just
your
fellow friends out there in like
the gaming industry the non-gaming
industry i think that like
allows everyone to create their best
work
yeah support your local communities
basically so there you go
listen we had to do it playing once is a
tradition for us
we love to see the projects everything
perfect then you guys come into fruition
so it's cool to see it's cool to see no
problem and again tell them one last
time so they know
get get a good trip it's out now all
platforms the information that you can
learn more about the game
feel free yeah yeah so you can check out
our website
redstart.io uh you can also just search
for get a grip chip
on steam and nintendo switch available
today
and coming soon to xbox nice switch gang
get it now
xbox hold tight it's coming get a grip
trip you already heard it here first
all right little podcast laura cognito
lords of gaming.net catch you guys later
[Music]
you